mais qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé dans
le désert
ouais c'est de me tuer c'est ici que
ciel ça fait longtemps vous êtes un ange
rejoint en faire six pages
si jamais vous avez envie de quitter
tout ça pour finir avec moins combien
d'enfants sont capables de danser sur
une tête des pailles
allez-vous par monsieur poule à mon avis
vous devriez je sais vous et qu'une
envie c'est de me tuer si j'ai bien
compris j'ai lange et vous la vis aux
vous et moi et les femmes vous devez
comprendre que tout change que tout a
une fin dans la vie pas ça
alors fais pas ça vous devez être
protégé
je confirme que vous êtes un miracle
tu crois que c'est amusant d'être un
monstre on dit que la dernière seconde
celui qui va mourir voit apparaître
l'avenir c'est hors de question voulons
les vrais comme tueur
je serai jamais comme les autres filles